hey check out Chris's new girlfriend at
Jeanine 1127 okay Oh
Jeanine she's all right I guess I mean
her hair is cute she's nowhere two thing
but it's kind of endearing yeah I guess
oh okay oh my god no no I just
accidentally tapped her picture oh my
god no oh why is it so easy to like
someone's picture Instagram why is it
just a to tab it should be like a for
tab for precaution what should I do
it's just like fit the other pictures
I'm just like 50 other pictures right
now oh that's dumb okay maybe I should
delete my Instagram account no I need it
for my friends and my family go for
creepin I just pack up and move away ah
I can't do that either
have a Yogurtland coupon I want to use
yeah maybe she won't see it maybe she
won't see it but the longer I wait the
longer she has to see it hopefully she's
on the toilet or something right now
wait no she's on the toilet then she
probably has her phone in her hand which
increases her chances of seeing it okay
our phone gets ran over it happens it
happened to me once how the chances are
low I was drunk that night you know what
I'm just gonna unlike it I just don't
like it
maybe she won't even notice I'm sure she
won't hey
hey Janine did you just let me Instagram
picture from 16 weeks ago maybe